here we go it's time to do the official
iPhone 6 unboxing I hope that you can
hear me if you can I'm really tired so
we'll fix it in post no he won't look in
a role she has a tool all right so we're
about to unbox the iPhone six-plus in
silver 128 gigs I've got my night
wait a minute night I've got my knife
further from your face much because I'm
gonna cut it all
usually frog box things I'd burned the
plastic off but I didn't want to bring
fire to the Apple store
it's really big
[Music]
all right that's really good it is
really messed up face there's an old
okay
[Music]
48 hours ladies and gentlemen boys and
girls it's all worthwhile
it has been my dream to be a person line
for any Apple store event and this is it
like we're here we're first Bonjour
ready for your first selfie on it or
what
and accessing my Terms of Service this
isn't boring at all this is all great
footage
everyone won't go through these steps
everyone has to watch you I'm trying to
see
I mean like a squished down iPad let me
got a top-heavy
it's going to take a few minutes to say
in the haven't seen any of these I can't
believe these are the new beats by dre
wait Dennis is that the fixed -
[Music]
because of you what's that what do you
think Oh bigger icons or thinner icons
this sin oh wow it's big
like
[Music]
I did it
wait you have a phone use gonna get set
up an ass
it's clear first selfie
oh are you happy put on Instagram
[Music]
look at it
I wonder if you're gonna dance our
pending iPhone store or the Apple Store
now oh my god it's so crowded look how
many people there are
Oh
which is plastic it's silicone silicone
doesn't get dirty plastic does no I'm
serious
[Laughter]
my case is on
how does it feel
I don't like the texture of it
well let's go interesting
we tried only dry feeling
all right believe in the Apple store it
is now 10 a.m. I have been here for
[Applause]
we're rolling out it all worked out and
Lamar got in this phone happy
it isn't haven't sown yet oh that's our
[Music]